Scot Osterweil: I want to
welcome everyone to this
evening's colloquium. I'm Scot
Osterweil. I'm the creative
director of the MIT education
arcade. And I've been
coordinating this fall's
colloquia.
Just my usual announcement,
which is, if you are someone
from the MIT community, you're
probably automatically promoted
to a panelist, which means at
the end of the talk, you're free
to sort of ask questions out
loud, verbally. If you are an if
you're an attendee, you're also
welcome to ask questions to the
q&a channel on zoom. So if if I
happen to recognize if somebody
I may promote you to panelist,
but otherwise, you can use the
QA QA function, just to raise
questions. Um, and with that,
I'm going to turn over, I'm
going to turn over the event to
Professor Heather Hendershot,
who's going to introduce our
speaker. And so Heather, take it
away.
Heather Hendershot: Hello, and
Hi, in particular, to those of
you who have not yet met, it's
nice to see you and little tiny
squares on my screen,
crushing your head.
I'm really delighted that we've
got Adam Hart here. speaking to
us today. He is the author of
this book, monstrous forms
Moving Image Horror Across
Media, which is a fantastic
book. He is currently working on
two other books, one on George A
Romero, and also a historical
and theoretical study of
handheld cinematography, and
film, television and video. Um,
and I mean, as far as the Romero
book goes, it's hard to imagine
anyone alive in America today,
or in the world who is better
positioned to write a book on
Romero from the archival
standpoint, at least. So I'm
really excited about that. And
I'm also really excited about
the other book on handheld
cinematography, it engages with
the avant garde with cinema,
very pay with newsreels, TV
documentaries, just a whole
range of texts. There's one
essay that's from this
forthcoming book that's already
been published in Discourse that
I encourage you to check it out
in that in that journal. Um, and
just in general, I really
appreciate Adam's work for its
theoretical and historical
rigor, but also, you know, for
the clarity and the precision of
his prose, it is really a
delight to read his work. Adam
is taught at Harvard at North
Carolina State University at the
University of Pittsburgh. He's
currently a visiting researcher
at the University of Pittsburgh
libraries, where his work
centers on the George A Romero
collection, which he will tell
you about right now. So on to
Adam.
Adam Charles Hart: Hello,
everyone. Thanks so much,
Heather. Thanks, Scot. So I'll
just say To start off, that I've
done a few versions of this
talk. And some are a bit more
sort of a slideshow, of all the
cool stuff from the George A
Romero archive. This one is a
little bit more focused. But
there's some digressions into a
bunch of just like, hey, look at
all this cool stuff I found. But
I can certainly indulge in much
more of that in the QA or if you
wanted to follow up, you know,
by email or whatever, at a later
time. I'm always thrilled to
talk about this stuff. Okay, so
I'm going to try to share my
screen.
All right.
Okay.
All right. So this talk is an
early attempt for me to process
the gigantic mass of material
that I've been sifting through
from Pitt libraries George A
Romero collection, which they
acquired last year. So Again,
this is a bit more focused, but
that's not to say there isn't
digressions. The story that I'm
going to tell in analyzing a
later film of Romero's veers
from beatnik theater to 2001, A
Space Odyssey fan fiction, to
Bigfoot to the Pittsburgh
Steelers to a Florida Community
College and a few other points
in between. And it's an evolving
story. In very literal ways. I
spent the last few months
sifting through hundreds of
scripts and boxes of materials.
But I've also been speaking with
Romero's collaborators, and
trying to track down leads about
other projects. One of the
amazing things about this
archive is that even though we
have literally hundreds of
hundreds of projects, we have
about 300 scripts for unproduced
films, the coming to about
100 120 distinct individual
projects, but everyone that we
spoken to mentioned some other
additional project that they
worked on with George Romero. So
we're finding more and more and
one of those leads suddenly
started to pay off in the last
couple of weeks. So one of the
projects that we'll be speaking
about today, briefly, is a short
film that's basically unknown
ever been screened publicly
called Jacaranda, Joe, that
Romero filmed in the 1990s. But,
again, it's never been publicly
screened. And suddenly, in the
last couple of weeks, I've been
able to get in touch with people
who worked on it, and people who
may have additional materials.
So while I've been, you know,
digging through the archive
here, I guess I'm also working
to build the archive and all
sorts of ways. And so, you know,
we'll we'll see where all of
this lands in the next few
months. Um, but anyways, I have
been calling this talk and it's
focused on cameras and
filmmaking in Romero's movie,
remarriages movies, what the
hell's with that camera anyway.
So, Night of the Living Dead
debuted more than 50 years ago,
in Pittsburgh on October 2 1968.
And nobody involved really knew
what to expect. A plucky band of
20 somethings but by co writer,
director and cinematographer
George A Romero had made what
they call a Pittsburgh's first
feature film, shooting largely
in a farmhouse just outside the
city. This ultra indie low
budget exploitation movie would
somehow grow in stature over the
next decade or so, getting a
shocking amount of
respectability for a black and
white movie from Pittsburgh,
about flesh eating corpses. But
the team that had worked around
the clock for more than a year
saw almost no direct profit from
a movie that truly changed
horror and in a lot of ways also
changed independent cinema,
distributor and competence put
the film in the public domain,
which meant that anybody with a
print could show it for free.
Well, distributor greed kept the
filmmakers from seeing all but a
fraction of the box office. It
was a success in cinemas but
because it was in the public
domain, it became a staple of
late night programming for any
TV executive looking to fill
time for free. And so throughout
the 1970s and into the 80s, it
went some pre internet version
of viral and scarred several
generations of children channel
flipping late at night in the
process. So the team managed to
get several more features under
their belt in the next few
years, trying to expand their
palate beyond the black and
white gut cruncher that made
them famous. But all those
movies were woefully
unsuccessful, playing only a
handful of theaters and not
receiving any widespread
distribution. So the team
disbanded more or less. Romero
stuck around in Pittsburgh
continued writing scripts, and
continued working to build a
local industry making
commercials TV industrials, but
he would really only get the
chance to return to features by
returning to the horror genre.
And by returning to his very
first film, with a sequel Dawn
of the Dead, but even then, it
took the cloud of high profile
fan, Dario Argento and his
European dollars to get it
financed. That sequel, Dawn of
the Dead would be a substantial
hit, but he stayed in Pittsburgh
as independently as he could.
Over the years. His brief
dabblings with the margins of
studio productions were wretched
experiences, and in 1999, after
about a decade of frustration
and inability to get a feature
into production, he moved his
filmmaking a few hours in worth
to Toronto were a friendlier tax
code and government support made
intimate, independent
productions easier to undertake.
So Romero never sought to become
a horror specialist. And he
certainly never intended to
corner, the market on flesh
eating zombies, but it wouldn't
work. And he found ways to bring
themes, tones and styles from
his other projects into the
films he was able to make. And
for filmmakers, fiercely
independent, and as far removed
geographically from Hollywood as
he was, he had a productive
career, directing 16 features,
several of which have become
Beloved, even outside of the
genres diehards. So he and his
friends invented a new Monster,
the undead zombie, that had
taken hold in the global
imagination in a way that maybe
no other 20th century monster
had. When was the last time a
filmmaker invented a myth as
pervasive and recognizable as
the Romero's zombie the
stumbling corpse driven only to
feed on the living? Every horror
fan knows and loves Freddy and
Jason and Michael and even
Frankenstein's monster, and Bela
Lugosi Dracula. But how many
Jason movies were made in South
Korea in the 2010s already out
arthouse legends like Jim
Jarmusch making Nightmare on Elm
Street movies, how many of my
all my Michael Myers musicals
Have there been? And I just
recently learned of the
existence of Disney Channel,
zombie teen musicals, which I
suppose I have to figure out a
way to watch now just out of
pure curiosity sake.
To find other kinds of films
with this sort of global
footprint, you'd probably have
to go to gigantic blockbusters
like Jaws, and Star Wars. But
that kind of pervasive cultural
influence comes at a price. We
know Romero is the man who gave
us zombies and who made a bunch
of zombie movies. And that's how
distributors and financiers knew
him as well. His few attempts to
stray from zombie and zombie
adjacent movies did not leave
much of a dent at the box
office. And if some of them
recuperated as cold classics
over the years, they didn't
necessarily help him get his
next movie finance. After night.
He was the zombie guy to
studios, to funders to audiences
to critics to fans. He never
exactly resented that. He once
likened it to a golden prison in
which the food is the best food
you've ever eaten. But it was
limiting in a way that did not
reflect his full artistic
ambitions. He stumbled backwards
into horror after failing to get
funding for previous features.
Most heartbreakingly for him
wine of the fond, which we have
production materials and a
script for it's an artsy coming
of age story tinted with
allegory that set in the Middle
Ages and clearly influenced by
Ingmar Bergman, and Orson
Welles. So in 2019, when the
University of Pittsburgh
libraries acquired Romero's
archives, we started to see a
very different story that could
be told about George Romero as
an artist. The archive shows a
remarkably prolific writer whose
interest so I guess this is the
actual archive here, whose
interest went beyond horror and
way beyond zombies, Western
slapstick kids movies, sci fi,
epics, cartoons, talky dramas,
and on and on and on. In all, we
have more than 300 drafts for
about 120 different projects
that Romero never got the chance
to film or publish during his
lifetime. There are mentions of
at least a dozen more that we
have come across in contracts,
and in correspondence or in
conversation with former
collaborators. Nearly everyone
we spoken to has mentioned at
least one other project that
Romero worked on, including
works with multiple drafts, they
got far enough into production
to begin raising money. As a
writer, he was astonishingly
prolific.
It's clear that some of the
shorter treatments were written
because writing them was fun. So
here we have an x rated
Frankenstein spoof called
Peterstein. That was written in
the 1970s from the 90s. A
bonkers little TV treatment
called nuns from outer space.
about aliens that happen to
resemble nuns and their language
happens to remember biblical
speak. The utterly delightful
monster mash this is my absolute
favorite thing in the archive.
Monster Mash is a comedy about a
team of mutants, monsters,
creatures in the light who
travel around the world to
administer emergency medical
trials. treatment to wounded and
alien monsters like themselves.
The title would be stylized with
ma sh all capitalized. It's
hilarious and delightful and
even though it's only 12 pages
long, Romero manages to work in
a rousing indictment of the
capitalist healthcare system. In
his brief proposal, and if
filming, it would have required
an effects budget, roughly equal
to the full budget of his
previous several features
combined. It ends with a jokey
decoration, the project's
financial promise. Think of the
fun No, forget the fun. Think of
the toys. The TV series The
animated version on Sunday,
Saturday morning think of the
bucks. Written in the mid 90s
when all of Romero's projects
seemed to be cursed, and film
after film turned to ash.
The irony of this conclusion was
thick and bitter and press
premise on the assumption, the
very idea of a George Romero
movie with a blockbuster budget
was utterly absurd. But that
didn't mean he couldn't have fun
writing it. So other stuff that
we have. In the archive, we have
photos of just amazing behind
the scenes photos that have
never been seen before, and
script pages from Night of the
Living Dead, that tell us a
whole lot about the actual
production. This is my all time
favorite bit of marginalia. From
the shooting script of Night of
the Living Dead. George realized
that he needed corpse shots for
a particular sequence. Here we
have an early version of Martin,
which is my favorite of Romero's
movies, which is not at all
about a teenage vampire. It's
about the vague on we have a
middle aged businessman. And
through this early fragment into
the early drafts, we can trace
its evolution to into what it is
on the screen. He made a he
wrote a bunch of scripts for sci
fi epics in the 1980s, including
War of the Worlds a
collaboration with fellow yinzer
and Marvel Comics legend, Jim
Shooter, a sort of setting the
future space superhero story.
And a, you know, maybe my second
favorite thing in the archive,
which is materials for a stage
adaptation of a space rock sci
fi musical tales of Hoffman, so
that he wanted to stage at
Carnegie Mellon University.
Okay, but we're going to focus
here on diary of the dead and
tracing back some ideas from
that. So in my book, and
elsewhere, I discussed the so
called found footage horror
movie typified by Blair Witch
Project internal activity. And
there I aligned the diegetic
camera, the camera that's
recording within the world of a
film with a kind of
vulnerability. It's a look
that's associated not with the
power and control of what
apparatus theory has dubbed the
gaze, but rather with weakness,
danger and exposure. It's always
partial and fragmentary and
always reminds the viewer of all
the unseen space just out of
frame and all the unseen threats
that may be lurking there. It's
exceedingly rare for a camera
operator to survive a found
footage film, which might not
seem unusual for a horror film
taken in isolation, but the
format of it guarantees the
death of the protagonist more
reliably than any other sub
genre. So you can see what I
mean here you guys hear Eric?
Okay.
Unknown: Very Oh
shit.
Adam Charles Hart: That's a very
young
Unknown: guys.
Guys What's happening? Hello.
Hello.
found this in one of the other
rooms tell us your name.
Sir.
Come on.
Say it.
Give me a break. Jake,
Jason,
Jason creed.
You see how it feels to have a
camera shoved in your face.
Adam Charles Hart: Okay, so
Romero in one of what would be
the first wave of found footage
movies. There's a weird sort of
lacuna where Blair Witch Project
comes out in 1999. And then in
2007 to 2008 a bunch of found
footage movies including
Cloverfield, wreck from Spain
diary of the dead and the first
theatrical festival version of
kernel activity all came out one
after another and so unique
among those Romero is
stigmatizing the problems and
sort of moral failings of
filming. But he's also aware of
this sort of fragmentary partial
nature of, of the camera and
calling our attention to
everything that we can't see.
Okay? So, um, shoot lost my
place. All right. So in diary,
which follows a group of
University of Pittsburgh film
students and their professor, as
the zombie apocalypse breaks out
during the filming of a cheesy
student horror movie, the
director of that student film
Jason creed, decides to document
the chaos with his video camera.
Remember, his movie consists of
sounded images recorded by creed
and its friends, including his
girlfriend, Deborah, we just saw
we as I suppose the film's
nominal protagonist, they are
not just camera operators, but
also editors, compiling their
footage and uploading it to the
internet as they go.
Unlike many of that first wave
of found footage, horror movies
were watching a completed film,
rather than raw footage. So
uniquely, the film openly
pathologizing Jason's need to
film and keep filming, with
other films with other
characters seeing it not just as
a distraction, but an intrusion,
a way of avoiding engagement
with a trauma befalling the
world that includes the
sometimes urgent danger that
flesh eating zombies inflict on
his friends. He insists on
experiencing the world through
the lens of his video camera,
and then uploading the next part
of his movie to social media
each time he finds a connection.
Again, the film pathologized is
its compulsion, likening it to
the zombie virus itself. The few
surviving characters ending the
film, shooting each other in
security monitors, after locking
themselves away from the world
in a panic room of a friend's
mansion. The lens of the camera
makes them unable to interact
with anyone on a human level. It
makes them in essence, less
human, feeding off the pain and
suffering of others. And it
seems to be transmitted
transmissible to anyone who
picks up a camera. It came
easily to you didn't it says the
film Professor Maxwell here,
calling Jason's film a diary of
cruelty. This is them shutting
themselves off at the end of the
film. And though Deborah, her
professor and one other students
survived the zombies by locking
themselves away from the world,
they've been infected by the
camera virus. Deborah finishes
the movie and uploads it online.
In her voiceover, she makes it
clear that she's finishing it
for Jason, an act of disavow
that rhymes with Jason blaming
his infection on his professor
earlier in the film, and which
has implications for the film's
understanding of the camera and
the camera virus. She's been
overtaken by Jason's illness and
has resigned herself to her
fate. There's no sense in her
work of Dr. urgency, no
enthusiasm in her voice. Jason,
she says thought he might be
able to make a difference, maybe
change the world. She has taken
up his mission, but she's merely
going through the motions, no
effect no drive of her own.
She's alive but isolated, active
her activities having been
reduced to the blank consumption
and production of images, the
completion of someone else's
work, work which seems to
actively to the test, as if she
lacks a will of her own. She is
essentially a zombie.
As with most found footage,
movies, the camera operator
Jason dies and then the typical
way of found footage is now
zombified friend, still in
costume from the mummy film
sneaks up behind him off camera.
Luckily for the purposes of
Deborah's edit, he manages to
turn around just in time to
catch a glimpse before the
attack. So this is what I mean
when I discussed the inherent
vulnerability for them fidget
footages diegetic camera, source
of anxiety and found footage
horror comes from the urgent
knowledge of the disparity
between the cameras viewpoint,
and the possible allegations of
threats. But it tends to be used
as an attempt to assert control,
capturing the threat in your
camera stabilizes it, and seems
to provide the kind of distance
or even security that Jason
presumes for himself. But those
around Jason, they clearly
understand him to be hiding
behind the camera as an act of
both cowardice and even cruelty,
filming and perhaps making
zombie movies in particular,
because Jason is making a zombie
movie. I'm being fundamentally
inhumane. So, why the film ends
with a coda that doesn't appear
in most drafts of the
screenplay, and why
Unknown: to play it. It's a
little less than a minute. For
those of you who see Night of
he Living Dead once said he
hought he could help
should look familiar, maybe even
save some lives. This is the
last thing he downloaded before
he died.
A couple of hometown Joe's who
went out to shoot at targets.
That day they used people, dead
people, you know, just for fun.
There was one target that was
different from the rest. A woman
tied by her hair to the branch
of a tree. The boys had this one
set up just for kicks. They got
out their favorite 12 gauge and
are we worth saving?
You tell me
Adam Charles Hart: if anybody
here is squeamish, I apologize.
That is the only bit of gore
that I'm sending your way in
this talk. I think. Okay, so for
those of you who have seen other
living dead, this is deeply
familiar. in that film, Ben, and
I'm gonna play this. on mute
while I talk. Ben, the African
American hero, it's a lone human
of the main characters to
survive the night after
surviving an onslaught of the
undead. He is as we see here,
he's killed by a posse of local
hunters and police, all white
varying German shepherds who
mistake him for a zombie and
shoot him right between the
eyes.
Unknown: right between the eyes.
Good shot. Okay, he's dead.
Let's go get another one.
Adam Charles Hart: Apologies to
anybody who hasn't seen it for
spoiling the ending of a 52 year
old film still, we're seeing
them. So in night, the tragedy
the gutting emotional
devastations of the ending comes
not just from the death of the
charismatic hero, but from the
realization that this white
posse fails to recognize his
humanity. In the original
script, they realized their
mistake, adding a note of bland
non committal regret. It's too
bad an accident, the only loss
we had the whole night in the
finished film. Instead, as soon
as he dies, the film immediately
cuts to still images of Ben's
body being dragged with meat
hooks and lifted onto a pyre. So
diary has none of that narrative
motivation to its zombie hunting
Kota. It's simple, dumb, cruel
spectacle, a bloody target
practice, with the targets being
people, dead people. But Deborah
identifies one zombie different
from the rest, a woman tied to a
tree branch by her hair, the
clear sadism, misogyny and lack
of empathy. For zombies or
humans or anything, the sheer
lack of recognition is chilling,
and the film fades to black with
Deborah morosely questioning
whether humanity even deserves
to be saved.
The monstrosity of filmmaking
and filmmaking as a pursuit
clearly reaches a pinnacle and
Romero's work here is it's hard
to go any farther. Where this
statistic spectacle for the
camera becomes an indictment of
the whole of humanity. with
cameras in 2007, getting smaller
and cheaper, and starting to
migrate onto our phones and
computers. We were all becoming
filmmakers and we're all
becoming consumers of images.
What damns us as a society is
not that this video was filmed
by a couple of quote hometown
Joes, or that people watch it,
that it's downloaded over and
over again. This is perhaps an
unexpected conclusion from a
horror filmmaker whose movies in
the 60s 70s and 80s were gory
enough to scandalize more
conservative viewers, and earn a
few bands around the world. This
suspicion of filmmaking,
however, was something that he
had been working through for a
very long time. Excuse me. So
this is where I'm going to
indulge in a few archival
digressions, but it all comes
back together a promise and an
envelope, and an envelope marked
old writings in the archive.
There were a number of short
stories, fragments and
treatments that Romero wrote in
the 60s and early 70s, including
two versions of a story, one of
which is titled enemies. Neither
is dated, but I feel safe
assert, asserting that the one
on the left, the untitled
shorter story came first. As it
is a barely elaborated, barely
altered version of the first
segment of 2001, A Space
Odyssey, in which two tribes of
pre human apes fight over
territory, and then on the right
and what I'm presuming to be the
second version, which retains
some of the same descriptions of
characters, and a basic
framework, Romero digs deeper
into the psyches of the proto
human characters into the
functioning of their society.
Through Romero's films and
screenplays, zombie films, in
particular, tend to be more
immediately concerned with the
monstrosity of humans,
vibrating, violent and cruel,
racist, misogynist, classist,
exploitative, and he thinks of
monsters as a kind of radical
alternative to humanity, and
crucially to human civilization
and structures of society. If
zombies are fairly blank
ideological vehicles, safer
their function of overturning
everything and feasting on the
remains, there's still a
progression throughout his
career as he becomes
increasingly concerned with
excavating traces of humanity
amongst the groundling feeding
on dead and zombie society
doesn't necessarily necessarily
model a kind of utopian
community. Some of his creature
scripts do. The zombies always
suggest an end to a society to a
cool society, expressing more
than anything else, an urgent
desire to start over, but the
creatures tend to provide a
different model you can follow.
So, Around this time, or
possibly a couple years later,
Romero was on his own in debt
and unable to raise money for
future productions. He was
writing a ton, but getting
nothing made besides commercials
and the occasional commission.
That is until he met a video
maker and technician named
Richard Rubenstein, who
interviewed him for a small
industry publication called the
filmmakers newsletter in 1973.
In those days video also
Intellivision, and after hitting
it off, the two of them started
cooking up ideas for
collaboration that could help
restore America's fortunes in
the world of production. Working
in Pittsburgh and utterly
unwilling to leave, Romero was
far from the centers of
production financing. He had a
tarnished track record and a
negative balance in the bank.
But he did have something a kind
of unique kind of local resource
that was utterly unique to this
to the city. The Pittsburgh
Steelers, who along with a
pirates and a handful of other
athletes, were leading a
remarkable sports renaissance in
a city that was otherwise
rapidly declining in both
economic and cultural standing.
Like other midsize cities with
longtime sports franchises, the
Steelers were incorporated into
the DNA of the place, an
essential cultural institution,
and at no time was that more
true than the 1970s and at no
time, were they more popular
outside of the city, either.
So, in 1973, Romero made a 50
some minute documentary about
the Steelers most popular player
running back Franco Harris, that
served as a sort of proof of
concept for the next sports
documentary, oj simpson juice on
the loose, which was broadcast
on national network television
in 1974. If you've heard of it,
it's because it received a minor
revival in the 90s as some of
Romero's collaborators tried to
capitalize on exploit symptoms
newfound infamy.
A brief aside, Romero was always
a vocal fan of Kubrick and a mix
of slapstick and blacker than
black satire of a film like Dr.
Strangelove can be seen in most
of America's films of the 1970s.
But weirdly, the oj documentary
was also a tribute to Kubrick.
The original concept for the
film was to give it a title
acknowledging Simpson's newly
broken rushing record that rift
on Kubrick 2003 yards a football
Odyssey titles, I have to say
were never a strength for
Romero, but that initial
inspiration remains in the
opening of the film, which is a
highlight montage set to
Zarathustra. So based on the
moderate but important success
of the simpson documentary,
Romero and Rubenstein use the
the Franco doc which they had
finished as the pilot for a new
TV series called The winners
that they'd spent the next year
that they'd spend the next year
and a half producing. It had no
network home, so it was more
like a group of specials
produced under the banner of the
winners than a conventional
television show. It consisted of
profiles of prominent sports
figures, largely but not
exclusively, Pittsburgh figures,
like pirates Hall of Famer
Willie Stargell, professional
wrestling pioneer Bruno
sammartino, and NASCAR legend
Mario and Ready. And most
importantly, three more
documentaries on various
Steelers players. Romero
directed a handful.
The Franco doc and the Bruno
sammartino doc are particularly
wonderful, as they double his
idiosyncratic portraits of the
city and its fans. But it
provided Romero and a growing
family of crew and collaborators
with regular work, laying the
groundwork for a film industry
in the Steel City, and making it
possible for America to continue
working in Pittsburgh with local
talent. But it would be several
years before you would get to
make another feature. So during
the production of the winners,
Romero and Rubinstein were still
trying to get features made. And
of course, the most logical
possibility was a sequel to
Romero's massively successful
debut. In early 1974. He met
with American International
pictures founded by Roger
Corman, along with James
Nicholson and Sam Markoff,
although only ARCA for me at
that time, about producing a
sequel called Dawn of the Dead.
The initial idea for Domine was
always was already there, a
small group of survivors
secluded from the chaos and the
zombie apocalypse in a shopping
mall. Though it would be several
years before the familiar
narrative structure and cast of
characters from the finished
film would fall into place. Hmm.
No film came from that meeting.
But the feedback was crucial for
Romero's efforts over the next
few years. AIP was interested in
interested in producing it, but
they were at the time looking to
market their films to quote
niche audiences. So they wanted
Romero to rewrite it for an all
black cast and they wanted to
put a superstar athlete in the
lead. Now there was really only
one athlete popular enough to
star in a movie at that time,
and Romero had just made a
documentary within OJ Simpson.
But Romero quickly found out
that oj wasn't available was an
interested, he was already
starring in a studio super
production, the Towering
Inferno, which would have been
both occupying Simpson's time
and probably pushing him out of
reach for AIP budgetary
possibilities.
So this AIP collaboration
fizzled out, but the idea of
using a high profile athlete to
get a feature made clearly stuck
with Romero. He had grown very
close to both the players and
the executives of the Steelers.
And if Franco Harris wasn't
famous enough to open a movie
made even on the margins of
Hollywood, he might be enough of
a draw for the purposes of
Romero's ultra indie low budget
productions, so he came up with
two projects for Franco working
with a Steelers organization to
various degrees on both of them.
The first is a truly bizarre
spoof of 50 creature features
and teen movies called monster
movie, in which Franco and which
ever Steelers they could get to
show up would play horny college
athletes trying to survive an
alien invasion. It obviously
never went anywhere. But Romero
obtained an official partnership
with the Steelers for a second,
a movie called footage which is
yet another atrocious title,
devised by Romero upon referring
to the creature Bigfoot. It's
built around a film crew that's
that's recording images,
footage, and possibly a triple
Pon also on NFL football. It's a
sort of promo found footage film
built around a film crew and the
images they've recorded but
never actually screening the
footage within the structure of
the film. So there are several
versions of the stories with
sometimes big variations.
And it's unclear as they're not
dated, which versions come
earlier or later. The basic
story is about a TV show called
outdoorsman, USA, or some slight
variation on that which Franco
would have started the guest
host on the TV show, a famous
NFL quarterback and one version,
a country music superstar as
well. The show's crew and
hunting experts would lead him
through the woods in search of
game, or at least that was the
show's premise. In the film,
they encounter a baby Bigfoot,
and someone carries a crying
child back to their camp. The
baby was not alone but part of a
society of big feet, living deep
in the woods, and they rush
after the kidnappers. The humans
in all versions respond
immediately with gunfire. In one
minute. In one version, a crew
member sees that the big feet
are intelligent enough to
understand what guns are. So he
holds his barrel against the
adorable baby big foots head as
would Night of the Living Dead.
The bulk of the film is devoted
to arguments within the group of
humans and demonstrating their
own inherent monstrosity, which
is contrasted directly with the
family can concern and love of
the Bigfoot society. He's also
clearly working out some of his
frustrations with the industry,
as the slimy anti semitic
producer tries to force the
camera operator to give him the
film of the big feet with a
camera operator resisting,
because he knows that that would
ensure the destruction of this
natural community in the woods,
one version of the film, one
version of the film ends with a
camera a camera operator and the
athlete winning the moral
arguments returning the baby
Bigfoot and discarding the film,
ending with the big feet
celebrating. They don't
understand what film is, of
course, in the script ends with
them throwing the reels in the
air like streamers. In some
versions, Romero returns to the
hostage taking, as the producer
holds a gun to the baby's head,
while an adult Bigfoot sneaks up
behind him and tears him into in
another the adult big feet
towering over the producer,
throw him in the cage the
producer had built to keep the
baby having been driven insane
by the trauma in screaming
making sounds that quote, are
almost identical to those of the
baby Bigfoot. The producer is
the villain and an all these the
cinematographer and crew only
earn absolution by destroying
the film.
Here are some of the designs fat
Bigfoot is your new favorite
monster, he's my friend and
yours. I was able to track down
one of the artists who does not
remember this at all, but after
jogging some memory, this,
there's no explanation for what
this is, but it was included
alongside the design. So it's
assumed that this is some kind
of a makeup test. Um, uh, so one
of the artists who are able to
crack down, we just sort of spit
balled for a while and our best
guess is that he would have
gotten this job through art
college. And so Ramiro would
have had some contact at various
art colleges and just put up a
flyer soliciting designs for big
feet for a movie and offering
you know, whatever little bit he
could pay, which was probably
fine for college students in
1975.
So this was yet another project
that never materialized, at
least not in that form. But the
idea never died. George Romero
loved Bigfoot, and he loved the
idea of building a story around
a camera crew in the forest. In
1994, George Romero was invited
to Valencia Community College, a
small but highly respected
school in Florida, to shoot a
short film as part of an
innovative, new endowed
position. This was a remarkably
fertile period for America, the
writer but an exceedingly
difficult one for America, the
director as project after
project fell through, and this
offered the increasingly rare
opportunity to actually get
behind a camera. The film
Jacaranda Joe was the first that
Romero shot wholly outside of
the Pittsburgh region, in the
arrangement with the college was
such that none of his usual crew
would be participating. So not
only has it never been screened,
it's almost entirely unknown. We
have a script, storyboards, and
a bunch of production documents,
and I might have tracked down
more. I've spoken to people who
worked on it. It was indeed
filmed and edited and it ran
about 18 minutes long.
So Romero conceived of the
script as proof as a proof of
concept for a feature. So
although it's structured to
stand on its own it consistently
gestures towards larger arcs.
The film is entirely different
from footage built around a
Geraldo like talk show called
Remington, in which the sleazy
host interviews, a series of
guests with info our opinion on
the opinions on the latest
regional news, which had brought
hundreds of people to a small
town in search of a glimpse. A
film crew shooting a TV show
about hunting and the outdoors
in their guest host a famous
athlete encountered a hairy ape
like creature in the swamps near
Jacaranda, Florida. The creature
was dubbed Jacaranda Joe, and
this is Joe. Okay, so, uh,
footage, use the device footage
the 70s film, or script use the
device of a film crew to discuss
the ethics of filming, and to
distinguish mundanities greed
and pettiness. From the more
perhaps stereotypically natural
existence of the Bigfoot
community. We would never
actually see the footage that
was filmed by the camera
operator. That was again the
crux of the dramatic conflict
within the film. The footage was
never found, but gleefully
destroyed before it could be
developed or viewed by anybody.
Jacaranda Joe takes the next
step in actually showing the
footage with attention to using
device of a sensationalist talk
show. This was Romero's attempt,
as he put it, to see if
audiences could be scared by a
documentary format.
Let's see in both footage and
Jacaranda, Jo, human like
creatures in the wilderness
offer sharp distinction to the
humans and film is essential to
that distinction. In footage, it
provides the potential to profit
while ensuring the destruction
of the community. One whose
survival is crucial for Romero
precisely because it suggests an
alternative possibility for
existence, to the greed and
violence of humanity, and of
course, the film industry. In
Joe that community may have
already been destroyed. Because
of the video, crowds have
flocked to the area, roses,
souvenir stands and food carts
line the main street of the
closest town and bikers rally
nearby for the hell of it. We
get only the briefest of
glimpses of the creature with no
indication of the larger swamp
ape community or family. What we
get instead is a representative
of the miccosukee tribe.
Another brief digression. One of
the actors considered for the
role of Benjamin the miccosukee
tribal leader was a local actor
and author of Choctaw Cherokee
descent, who provided the
producer with detailed notes on
Benjamin's portrayal that author
who had not yet published his
first novel was owl going back,
who had quickly become one of
the most revered horror
novelists in the country. And
fully separate from this
project, a collaborator with
Romero on yet another film for
which Romero failed to gain
financing. So Ben up his role is
cliched to say the least. But he
voices a strong critique of the
violence and indifference of
white society. He had been
arrested for killing a panther
with his bare hands, as was
required to join us tribal
council. And on the talk show he
gets in a shouting match with
quote, redneck hunters who want
to shoot more animals. He
responds more Panthers are
killed by rental cars than by
Native Americans, when they get
indignant at his own
transgressions. But he goes
further, asking white society to
respect the laws of his
community. Just as the
indigenous peoples have
respected there's Benjamin's
moral code requires him to tell
the truth, which as he points
out, white societies Judeo
Christian rules do as well. So
in both of these, sorry, so the
use of diegetic sorry, I just
got lost my apologies. Okay, so
I'm in in Jacaranda, Joe
Benjamin, helps to align the
critique of modern society that
Romero associates with
filmmaking with a kind of more
quote unquote stereotypically
natural existence when it's not
fun, problematic, obviously.
Okay, so this use of diegetic
camera operators to depict
filmmaking as a corrupting
force, however, goes back even
further past past footage past
the 1970s. even beyond the start
of Romero's own film career,
there are of course predecessors
to the found footage horror film
that were hugely influential to
Romero, including peeping Tom, a
film in which avoider murders
women with a camera outfitted
with a knife, and Orson Welles
radio broadcast of War of the
Worlds. Powell and wells were
two of America's favorite
filmmakers mentioned frequently
in interviews as influences and
inspirations. War is actually
directly referenced in diary and
Romero had clearly been thinking
about it at least since he wrote
his war of the world script in
the 1980s. Well, Powell was not
only possibly Romero's biggest
inspiration, but he became a
friend of Romero's late in pals
life. right around the time he
would have been working on
Jacaranda, Joe.
So both of those works have been
mentioned by critics and fans as
clear ancestors of The Blair
Witch Project. But there is one
work that to my knowledge never
has, and it is even more crucial
to Romero's artistic biography.
In 1960, just after he turned 20
years old, Romero joined his
friend Rudy Richie in a small
production of jack Gilbert jazz
play, the connection, the
sensation of New York theater in
1959, the essential avant garde
theater troupe The Living
theatres production helped
inaugurate a new era of American
drama. Largely plotless. The
play consists of a bunch of
beatniks and junkies and jazz
musicians waiting for their
heroin dealer. Romero who would
later claim that he was
recruited primarily because he
was large, played leech, the
owner of the rundown loft in
which all the junkies await
their fix, accompanied by an
opportunistic writer and two
cinematographers, all of whom
hope to event to ultimately
exploit these subjects for a
film. One of the subjects grows
frustrated and unleashes on the
filmmakers, accusing them of
treating his life and the lives
of his friends as a freak show.
So the influence of this laid
back almost structuralist
improvisatory collaborative play
was a parent even in something
like Night of the Living Dead.
If the connection is about a
bunch of junkies stuck in a
stuck in a craft the crappy
apartment until their Dior's
arrives, getting more and more
jumpy, intense. The night
basically transposes as basic
dynamic to the wildly
fantastical dynamic of the
zombie apocalypse. Um, but even
at that stage of it even at the
earliest stage of his career,
filmmaking is opportunistic and
destructive. It fundamentally
exploits its subjects and
asserts a dehumanizing distance
from behind the lens. Romero Of
course, did not write the
connection. In any discussions
of influence, however, formative
they may be are fuzzy at best,
but there seems to be a direct
line between the connection and
diarrhea of the dead with a
remarkable consistency. It's
even there in Night of the
Living Dead, where the news crew
led by beloved local TV host and
newsman and Romero's early
benefactor chili, Billy bill
Cordell, is benign and
apparently performing essential
work. But even a cuddly local
hero like chili, Billy is
aligned with the all white posse
that shoots Ben right between
the eyes. But of course, with
diary, the denunciation becomes
explicit and explicitly aligned
with horror movies. As Jason's
hacky mummy movie we see at the
beginning of the film, gives way
to a grittier, more realistic
zombie movie that destroys the
lives of everyone around him.
So there's undoubtedly some
dimestore psychologizing of
Romero himself that we could do,
and we might not be incorrect.
But I want to think of this as
intentional rhetoric, one that
is consistent with a filmmaking
ethos that drove him to remain
independent, remain far from the
centers of finance in
production, adopting a mode of
filmmaking that is collaborative
and unregulated that remains
flexible and open to change over
the course of shooting in
invites contributions from
everyone on set. What makes in
diary, the dead the filming
virus, so seductive and so
dangerous, is how easily it
becomes exploitative and
alienated, alienating how
quickly it becomes an agent of
distance. If he'd been infected
by the camera virus, he'd spent
a lifetime interrogating it even
trying to combat it. But he was
always ambivalent about his
legacy in his career, and for
him, the diegetic camera and
eventually the found footage
film was an especially potent
means of making critique.
So as I said before, the
diegetic camera in found footage
horror tends to communicate
vulnerability first and
foremost, offering a partial
fragmentary view of a scene,
which monsters and other threats
might be lurking. The camera
operators and diary Jason in
particular, use their cameras as
a way of distancing themselves
from the events in front of
them. But that distance
primarily manifests in a lack of
intervention. Jason cannot help
or offer support to the to the
people who are in danger or
suffering, because he is hidden
behind his camera, and in the
end, zombie sneaks up behind him
and bites him as soon as he
spends his camera around. The
camera is ultimately impotent,
signaling both a lack of control
and a lack of protection,
driving away his friends
endangering them and ultimately
causing his own death. The
ending in which survivors lock
themselves away from the world
to edit the footage and film the
security mom monitors ironies as
Jason's fantasy of the cameras
gaze. They're kept safe, but
only by literally locking
themselves off from the rest of
the world. If this is ultimately
what Romero thinks of the
cameras, powers and dangers,
it's a critique a denunciation
even in which he includes
himself. But the critique also
offers a path to a solution. It
filmmaking is up isolating and
inhumane, but it requires a
communal collaborative approach,
when which issues the
temptations of big budgets
studios, in which allows for a
kind of collective expression,
or at least an expression of
community. To paraphrase Romero
from an interview in the 1980s,
the greatest tragedy of a zombie
apocalypse would not be for
humanity to be overthrown. But
for the survivors to fall back
into old patterns, and society
to reset as it was before, diary
is his most pessimistic work,
because he can't see to the
other side of the camera virus
has infected everyone. And even
if we survived the flesh eating
zombies will be making and
consuming images on our own
forever. Thank you.
Heather Hendershot: Thank you so
much.
Whoops,
can you guys hear me?
Adam Charles Hart: I can hear
you. Oh, good. Hello, thank
Heather Hendershot: you so much,
Adam. That was really, really
fascinating. It was wonderful to
see all those archival
materials. Um, I wonder if I,
I'd like to kick us off with two
questions, and they're totally
different. One is about diary of
the dead, which, um, you have so
ably explained as a critique of
filmmaking and the notion of the
camera virus and so on. But it
also is very much as you know, a
sort of attack on social media,
and phones and blogs, and the
kind of it's kind of a grumpy
old man movie in certain ways of
like,
Adam Charles Hart: hundred
percent. Yeah,
Heather Hendershot: but they're,
you know, um, and I wonder if
you could talk about that angle
of the film, which, of course,
is sort of ironic, because it's
a film that mostly saw digital
distribution, and people
probably watched on their phones
a lot and stuff, you know,
because it was so minimally
distributed. Or that right? Um,
so that's, that's one question.
And the other one is totally
different. And it's, you know,
when you were talking about some
of the earlier films, you know,
after neither Living Dead, um,
you kind of hopped over a freak
show. And I'm wondering if you
talk a little bit about creep
show, a place within his career.
And, and, you know, I'm just
thinking about it financially,
because you're talking about so
many of Romero's struggles, and
creep show. I don't know the
numbers at all, but I would be
shocked if it were a box office
disaster, it seems so
marketable. It's got some of the
biggest stars, he had probably
the biggest stars he had before
Land of the Dead, right? I mean,
like how Holbrook first Ed
Harris is not like big at that
point. But, you know, it's got
Stephen King. So it's got some
sort of cult appeal from that,
or Adrian barbeau. Fritz Weaver.
So I've just those two questions
if Yeah.
Adam Charles Hart: So I'll start
off with creep show. So after
the success of Dawn of the Dead,
he was able to parlay that into
a three picture deal. And he had
financing and creative freedom
for the first and only time in
his career for those three films
with some caveats. One of them
was going to be a horror film
that was a collaboration with
King and the other one had to be
another sequel to Dawn of the
Dead. So Day of the Dead would
be the third one creep show
would be the second. And the
first he just had complete free
reign. So he makes Knight
Riders, which is a movie about a
modern day motorcycle jousting
troupe that's modeled after
Camelot and Renaissance fairs.
It's crazy. I like the film
quite a bit. But the idea that
he could have thought of that as
commercial in any way is
remarkable. But crypto did fine.
Like it didn't do great. It
didn't do terrible. It sort of
found its niche audience on
video over the years. It I think
it was number one at the box
office, the first week that it
opened. And then the studio for
some reason, pulled all ads, and
it sank very quickly. So like,
again, it did fine, wasn't a
disaster, Day of the Dead was a
disaster. It was a film that was
you know, Dawn of the Dead. Like
has a lot on its mind. But it's
also like candy colored and fun
and funny. And Day of the Dead
is grim and kind of unpleasant
in a lot of ways. And did not
excite audiences in the same
way. And the failure of Day of
the Dead killed a lot of
opportunities. Whereas creep
show like again, it did fine,
but they have the dead was
always going to be the next
movie. Yeah. But the other
question wait was Question.
Heather Hendershot: Sorry, the
dad is a cranky old man movie
about Oh, yeah.
Adam Charles Hart: Oh,
absolutely. And it was made in
2007. So like the height of
MySpace basically. And there's
very clearly a kind of grumbling
towards young filmmakers, like,
especially young filmmakers who
want to be horror guys, that you
see in a lot of Romero's, like,
just very, like interviews and
writings and in his films late
in his life, I think there's,
for him kind of a little bit of
resentment, resentment that he
got saddled with, or there's all
these people who are like,
that's their only aspiration is
making a dumb zombie movie or
whatever. Um, but he also
clearly sees, okay, so if it is
a grumpy old man movie in which
social media is the problem,
it's coming before Facebook
before iPhones had been, had
been introduced. And I think
that what he's seeing is not
just like the kids with their
phones, but everybody turning
into someone who's experienced
with each other is mediated by
screens. And as he would
understand that, as filmmakers,
as photographers, and as
audiences, which is a kind of
relationship that he's very
suspicious of, and that he's
always sort of trying to arrange
new arranged new configurations
for, for how the filmmaker can
relate to audiences. And so, you
know, I would have liked to have
had a conversation with him, you
know, in the 2010s, about what
he thinks of all these kids in
his in their phones. But, yeah,
I mean, he tends to align
technology of any kind with a
kind of corrupting influence
with this, you know, kind of
stereotypical ideal of a more
natural kind of existence that
you see with big feet, or, you
know, the proto humans and his
Stanley Kubrick fan fiction, or,
you know, once again, very
problematically with the
miccosukee tribe in Jacaranda,
Joe. And to some extent, kind of
with the zombies and like Land
of the Dead, or survival. So
yeah, I don't know. He's always
going to grumble about it.
Heather Hendershot: Great, thank
you. Who else has a question?
Amber,
Ámbar Reyes: thank you. Hi,
ma'am. Thank you so much for
your talk. I was wondering if
you know, which was the last
clip that he wrote that couldn't
produce? Because I mean, like,
you have been telling us that he
couldn't produce alert. But I
like the last one, because he
died or something like that. And
what I was also wondering, what
do you think he would be
producing right now? Like, we'd
all these like social media
together.
Adam Charles Hart: So it's
difficult to say, because at a
certain point in the 21st
century, in particular, he
realized that not only it like
it had gotten worse, not only
was he could he only get funding
for horror, but he could only
get funding for zombie movies.
And more than that, only for
living dead sequels. So that's a
lot of what he worked on in the
last like 10 years of his life,
basically. But the last script
that he worked on, that I know
about, is an adaptation of a
novel called the zombie
autopsies, which was written by
Steve Schwarzman, who's like a
buddy of mine, he teaches at
Harvard, in the psychology
department, and they were never
able to get funding for it. And
they worked on this for a couple
of years, going all around, you
know, Hollywood and independent
producers and all that and just
never came to anything. But the
last thing, so there's there's
two final projects that are both
really interesting, and they're
both written. One is a short
story called The Liberator.
That's a Gollum story that you
can find online. It was a
collaboration with his longtime
friend, George nama, who's
currently married to his ex
wife, Christine Forrest, but who
he'd known since the 1950s. Like
since he first moved to
Pittsburgh. And, you know,
George was the one who actually
introduced him to the owners of
the Monroeville mall, so that he
could shoot Dawn of the Dead
there, they've been talking
about collaborating for a while.
So George nama is a renowned
visual artists now. And this
collaboration was for a gallery
exhibit, where nama would
provide the visuals, etchings,
and Ramiro would write a story.
And it's, in some ways very much
a grumpy old man story. But it's
really fascinating and moving
and you can you can find it
online. It's a it's a catalog
for the exhibit, but it contains
the full story. And the other
thing was, at a certain point,
when he realized he wasn't going
to get, maybe he wasn't going to
get to make a film again. But he
definitely wasn't going to get
the kind of budget he wanted
again. So we started writing a
novel that was about a quarter a
third of the way done when he
passed away. And it was an
attempt to kind of summarize,
but also further the zombie
mythology and trying to tie
everything together. It was
finished by Daniel Krauss after
Romero's death and came out a
couple of months ago, it's
called the living dead. It's
really great. And you may find a
character about halfway through
who shows up named heart. It's
not a coincidence. It's the
coolest thing that's ever
happened to me, which is that in
the George Romero, zombie novel,
my buddy Dan wrote me in as a
character. So yeah. But other
than that, I don't know what he
would be working on, because you
see just like a drop off in
production at a certain point,
when he sort of like he's old,
but also like, just like he had
had in the 90s and early 2000s.
So many projects fell through.
And like that happens to any
filmmaker. But when you're
working like as independently as
he did, like, everything has to
go right for a film to get made.
So like, one project got
cancelled, because it was too
similar to this new Keanu Reeves
and Sandra Bullock movie called
speed that was gonna beat them
to theaters, there was another
one where somehow it all hinged
on getting a star like Sharon
Stone to be in it, and they
somehow got the money to offer
her $12 million, or something
like that. And she turned it
down, because she didn't want to
be in a fucking ghost movie. He,
he does that kind of impression
when he tells the story. And
there's just like, lots of
little things like that. And it
just happened so many times
that, you know, like, at a
certain point, and at a certain
point in your life, like when
you're in your 60s, I think you
stop writing a script every day.
And stop, like having that
ambition to make your science
fiction epic that adapts tales
of Hoffman into a space rock
musical. You know, in. So it's
mostly zombie stuff in the 21st
century. And not much else,
besides the projects that God
made? After like, 2005 or six? Yeah.
Unknown: Thank you.
Heather Hendershot: Who's next?
I can't see everyone's hand. But
I see Laura.
Laura Partain: Hey, Adam, thank
you so much for your
presentation. I found it
fascinating. I have to admit
that my question is coming
directly from what you
presented. And because I myself
and have not watched these
films, I don't do well with her.
Although I very much appreciate
her. I'm trying to get better at
that. So I'll make it a point to
watch some of these soon. My
question is kind of thinking
about like two questions, but
one is thinking about how you
you talked about that there was
increasing isolation or he
represents increasing isolation
due to the over mediatization or
us each other through screens
only. and wondering if there was
also influence particularly of
kind of neoliberal policies that
were coming out in, you know,
the 80s 90s that were affecting
the Pittsburgh community if that
had any effect on on his work as
well. It's, it's just hard for
me to, you know, when I hear
things about isolation, or even
when you're talking about what
seems to be ethics of care with
Bigfoot, and caring for the
family, it's really hard for me
to think that that may not have
had some sort of influence on
him. And I'll quickly add the
second one just so anyone else
can get in. The second one has
to do with I was really
interested when he talked about
The use of a black character in
his first film and, and that
that wasn't necessarily a choice
and how interesting that is, but
that it seemed like he almost
leaned into kind of a racial
narrative in terms of, it's hard
to ignore the it looking like a
racial lynching the way that the
final film came out. So I'm
wondering about the effects of
that, if you could just talk
about this two things, please.
Adam Charles Hart: Yeah,
absolutely. So, um, in terms of,
like, the, the politics of the
90s and 2000s, um, it drove him
out of Pittsburgh, basically,
you know, the, the tax code and
various other, you know, right
wing, or neoliberal, sort of
changes within the state made it
almost impossible for him to
film here. And so it doesn't
seem like a coincidence to me
that all of his stuff in the
21st century, you know, for
films that he shot in Toronto,
or at least in Canada, they all
feel very, they're very much
about isolation and seclusion.
It's not that that's not there
before, but it seems to have
like a different sort of
manifestation in those movies.
Because like the community in
Pittsburgh, and the city, in the
sort of family of filmmakers
that he had developed, were all,
always incredibly important to
him, you know, you see you read
interviews with him from just
after Night of the Living Dead,
or actually even before that,
and he's as interested in
building a film industry in
Pittsburgh, as he is in making
the next movie. Now, of course,
he's, you know, obviously
interested in making the next
movie also. But, you know, he,
he doesn't leave for Hollywood,
which, you know, if you don't
make any money off of Night of
the Living Dead, the way you
cash in on it, is to use it as
your calling card at all the
studios and then get that gets
you in the door. But that never
even occurred to him. Instead,
he wanted to build Hollywood on
the mom, which is not a very
catchy tagline, but which I see
repeated a few times in the
early 1970s. And so, you know,
when he has to like it, it very
literally drives him away. And
at a time after, which, like, in
the early 1990s, like he seemed
to have succeeded, there were a
bunch of high profile film
productions that he did not
make. That was that were in
Pittsburgh. And so like, his
friends, his colleagues, you
know, a whole new generation of
filmmakers, got to stay in the
city and got to keep working.
And you know, there wasn't
really a film school here at the
time. And so, you know, there's
a whole generation of film crew
and producers and such who
basically learned how to make a
movie on the set of Silence of
the Lambs or Night of the Living
Dead, or, you know, this really
strange john Landis movie called
innocent blood, or some of
George's like, late 80s, early
90s Productions. And then over
the course of the 90s, it
basically makes it impossible
for mistake. Um, I do think that
he thought about things in a
sort of, he did have a political
perspective on on the world, but
that the way that it would have
manifested most viscerally for
him was in that literal exile
from the community that meant so
much to him. And, God, I did it
again, I forgot what the second
question was.
Laura Partain: In the Night of
the Living Dead,
Unknown: oh, yeah.
Laura Partain: Thank you that
thank you very much for the
first answer as well. Okay.
Adam Charles Hart: Um, so, you
know, he always he always
claimed that it was completely
unintentional, that Dwayne
Jones, the actor was just the
best actor who showed up. Um,
but that's bullshit. Like, yes,
they did not write a script,
intending it to be, you know,
intending it to be like a civil
rights, you know, didactic,
cracked or whatever, but you
don't have a script in which a
black man slaps a white woman
and shoots a white man and then
have you know, like a white
posse with German Shepherds,
kill him. You don't do that
unless you know that what the
political resonance is like,
these are choices that you know,
you would have to be not just
naive but stupid to not
understand like had some kind of
meaning. And you know, it. I
think that at some level, he
recognized that that gave the
film, a kind of thematic
ambition that a lot of that a
lot of horror Films didn't have,
although it's not uncommon for a
science fiction film, and George
was a huge fan of like 50
science fiction. You know, in
later years, he and other like,
horror fans would kind of
denounce there's a corny science
fiction explanation about
radiation from the moon or
something that may have caused
the dead to rise. I don't know,
we shouldn't have no no
explanation, no explanation that
makes it cheesy and corny, but
that's what he was into. He
likes cheesy science fiction
movies.
And it's not unusual for science
fiction movies to have that sort
of political commentary,
particularly about racism and
intolerance. Like, that's
something you see in, you know,
50s and 60s, science fiction
over and over again. Um, and so,
like, I think at some level, he
recognized that he could use
this movie for that. I think,
like, he's sort of a, you know,
like, more sort of, like, middle
of the road liberal in the sense
that he's much more concerned
with, like, acknowledging the,
like, the value of one's
humanity, rather than exploring
the, you know, like, specific
oppressions of being a black man
in America in 1968. Or, you
know, like, the, the specifics
of what misogyny or homophobia
means at the time that he's
making a film. But that doesn't
mean that they're, they're
completely absent, like, he's,
you know, has this kind of vague
sort of a humanist approach to
politics, vaguely humanist, I,
you know, whatever, anyways, um,
but he thinks that it's
important, and he and he's
really driven by this sense of
like society needing to change
even in his more optimistic
views, like, is he is more
optimistic movies are mostly
optimistic about like, being
able to tear down the whole
system and start something else.
You know, at night writers,
which, again, bizarre movie
bizarre choice to make, like, I
got free rein, I'm gonna make
the motorcycle gesture movie,
like, that's what crazy. But
it's all about like a community
that sort of forms on the
outside of society with its own
rules. That's all about like,
honoring each other, and
following a different code than
everybody else follows. And so
in a lot of ways, like Knight
Rider feels like this key to his
entire filmography, you know, of
him wanting to build a different
kind of society, basically.
Yeah. long winded answer. event,
but, yeah.
Vivek Bald: Thank you so much
for your for your talk. I wanted
to follow up on what you were
just saying. And also, I mean,
just it seems like there's a
theme throughout much of what
you're talking about, in which,
you know, that makes me think
that the kind of critique of the
act of filming critique of the
camera as as sort of
dehumanizing
Unknown: that
Vivek Bald: on on a more
specific level, could, could
that be seen as a critique of
Hollywood itself, you know, from
someone who was an outsider, not
just by choice, but also by
these constant rejections,
right. of his scripts. And and
so even the idea that you just
mentioned, a creating an
outsider society, you know,
echoes with what you were saying
earlier about the kind of
outsider community of filmmakers
that he fostered in Pittsburgh.
So I'm curious to hear about,
you know, either specifically in
the archive in his own writings
or interviews or letters, you
know, what, what you found of
him talking about Hollywood as
an industry,
Adam Charles Hart: he absolutely
hated it. Um, you know, he I
think he's one of those people
who never sold out because he
was physically incapable of
doing so. You know, he got a
couple of opportunities as a
teenager to be like a PA, on
some Hollywood productions,
including one, I think North by
Northwest. And it really sort of
soured him on the way that
Hollywood works. You know, he
liked Hitchcock, but he was
never like a, he was never
somebody who he brought up in,
you know, like in interviews as
an inspiration or something like
that, and I think it's because
of that experience, where
everything seemed so rigid. And
Hitchcock was always sort of in
battle with the studio having to
find ways to work around them.
And that largely came through
like, very inflexible planning
for everything. But what he
really disliked about Hollywood
was this sense of the sense of
exploitation at the expense of
the filmmakers, this sense that,
like, the people who are making
the film don't get to decide
what the film should be. And in
his, you know, his for tations,
with Hollywood with a film
called monkey shines, that's,
you know, it's good, but flawed,
let's say, he was forced to film
a, like, an absurd, happy
ending, that, you know, takes
place in the, well, in the
building that I'm in right now,
it takes place right outside of
it. So, like, I kind of
appreciate that about it. But I,
you know, he's, it's, it is
absurd, and is experienced
filming the dark half Stephen
King adaptation with, you know,
a, what they used to call a mini
major studio was the worst
experience of his life. His wife
at the time, believes he had a
stroke in the middle of it just
from stress.
And, you know, when all of that
money gets involved, and all of
those, you know, intermediaries,
then it becomes the decisions
are not made, based on what
makes the film better or worse,
in the kind of free flowing way
that you'd like to work. And
that he thought was a lot of
fun, sort of disappears. And so
in the 90s, you know, I said he
couldn't get a film made. But he
was able to get a bunch of
scripts sold. And I think he
just sort of like, had a sort of
working retirement like he was
around 60, at that time, and he
loved writing, he managed to
make it into a sort of
collaborative effort where he
would work with his producer,
but he'd also bring in, you
know, novelists, and filmmakers,
and all sorts of people and
they'd, you know, like, they'd
drink and smoke, and come up
with a new script. And if he was
all alone, he just like wake up
in the morning and put on ESPN
or old movies and start typing
away at his typewriter. And so
in a lot of ways, like, that
sort of becomes his vocation
more than actual filming of
movies. Um, but, you know, there
was a lot of resentment that was
obviously changed with
bitterness. You know, at a
certain point, he did like he
would have liked to have sold
out to make War of the Worlds or
his adaptation of the stand, or,
you know, like he did have like
big ideas. But Hollywood
basically considered him and
immature, even though Dawn of
the Dead and Night of the dead
had been, you know, big hits,
because he had never worked in
the studios before. So I think
that only sort of cemented his
resentment of Hollywood. Yeah.
Heather Hendershot: In that
context, could you talk briefly
about Land of the Dead as a
studio picture, I saw him at a
screening of diary of the dead.
And he wasn't completely
negative about land of the dead,
but he had not enjoyed the
production experience at all.
And he expressed quite a bit of
relief, you know, to do the
diary of the dead after that,
and you know, just enjoying no
longer being beholden to the
suits who are bossing around and
so on. I mean, at the time, I
thought, yes, but Land of the
Dead is like really solid, and
in many ways, a better film than
diary, the dead. Yeah, but
that's not how he saw it, I
think.
Adam Charles Hart: So I've
talked to a couple of people who
worked on land of the dead, and
it was it was kind of a
horrifying experience for George
because it was so intense. It
just required so much of him in
the sense that he was, you know,
like, he was not just making the
film but like answering to all
of these suits and managing the
sort of logistics for what we
was probably his biggest
production at that point. And,
you know, I think he's very bad
at the logistics. He's a
terrible businessman. He's
terrible at organization, like
his ideal is kind of Night of
the Living Dead. Like he always
was sort of like, trying to
chase that Dragon of Night of
the Living Dead. But with money
enough to print out a new draft
of the script, when they made
some changes or so that everyone
didn't have to sleep on the
floor of the house. They're
they're filming in. But Land of
the Dead was the film on which
like, it had been so long since
he had had a hit. Like his
entire career, his ability to
ever make a film, again, was
writing on it. He had made one
film in the previous decade. And
it was bruiser, a film, which
I'm guessing nobody here has
seen, because almost nobody has
seen it. And certainly, okay, I
should have known. But not very
many people like it
Unknown: was a
Adam Charles Hart: it was a
pretty notorious flop. And the
only way you know as with Donna,
the dead, making another sequel
was the only way he could get
back into feature filmmaking. So
so much was riding on it that he
just like was putting in 20 hour
days, he was like, in his way he
would have been in his 60s at
that point. So he, you know, was
exhausted? And like, I don't
think he could physically have
ever done that again. I do think
that his opinions of his movies
are largely based on his
experience filming them. Yeah.
So he loves night writers
because it was the most fun
movie. Like he hung out with his
friends in the country. And you
know, like he Ed Harris got
really close. And they rode some
motorcycles and made the Tom
savini pose in a speedo. And,
you know, like, just had a bunch
of had a bunch of picnics and
such, you see the behind the
scenes, pictures, and it's like
one big party. But you know,
like Land of the Dead, I think
is one that he likes the movie
fine, but he does not look back
on it with particular fondness.
For that reason, I think
Heather Hendershot: I would put
in a quick plug for land of the
dead because I know some of us
here don't want to I think Laura
identified herself as not
watching a lot of horror films.
And maybe some of you haven't
seen many or any Romero movies.
And Land of the Dead is a real
standout for me as a not a post
911 movie, and as a film
critical of George W. Bush, and
maybe the first theatrical
feature, American theatrical
feature to really kind of take
that on in a serious way through
the allegory of science fiction
slash horror. So I think it
might be a good starter film for
some people who maybe don't come
to it as zombie lovers or if
you're not as but when you sit
in that political context.
Adam Charles Hart: Yeah, it was,
I mean, it was the most
political theatrical release of
was that of whichever year was
released, like just after the
Iraq war started, and it was
like, you know, there was no
other theatrical film that was
that explicitly political. Yeah,
Unknown: the only other thing I
can think of around that time it
would be the masters of horror
episode homecoming, which is not
ethical film, but like, if
another zombie movie,
right So Laura just said like
that could get me into horror. I
would also recommend the masters
of horror Showtime series
episode called the homecoming,
that is a zombie episode that is
very harsh about George W. Bush.
Adam Charles Hart: Yeah, for
some reason, the like, elder
statesman of horror, got
together and decided that zombie
movies in 2005 or 2006 zombie
movies were the proper vehicle
for denouncing the Iraq War. In
inland of the dead Dennis Hopper
is doing it Donald Rumsfeld
impression. And you know, like
the it's it's his most
explicitly political film with
like a capital Pete like, it's
about politics. You know, I
think that subtlety is overrated
as a as an aspect of cinema.
Heather Hendershot: Yeah,
homecoming homecoming, which is
not Romero to be clear. It's um,
is it Joe Dante?
Scot Osterweil: It's true,
Dante. Yeah,
Heather Hendershot: yeah. Um,
but uh, homecoming, like
features voting prominently,
like zombie voting. Yeah, I want
to say more than that. But we're
at a moment we're thinking about
voting on ticularly good.
Adam Charles Hart: And I'll just
I'll just say like so, um, you
know, this, this talk was cut
down considerably from the first
draft that could have lasted
three. But one of the things
that I talked about in there
was, you know, it's not just
that Romero kind of stumbled
backwards into horror after he
couldn't get other stuff made.
But he kind of only made one
movie that ever tried to scare
people, like Night of the Living
Dead was a very scary movie for
1968. I don't know if it'll give
you nightmares in 2020. Not just
because, you know, reality is
scary enough. But, um, you know,
after that he would use horror
as a way to, you know, tell
different kinds of stories,
whether it's a zombie movie, or
a vampire movie, or, you know,
creep show, which is like an
adaptation of 50s or a
transposition of 50s. You know,
cheesy horror comics, like,
they're all thought of as
horror, and I guess they are,
but it's not horror in the sense
that they're trying to, like,
scare you or give you
nightmares. They're using
monsters and horror tropes to do
whatever he was interested in,
basically.
Heather Hendershot: Um, it's
635. We could take another maybe
one last question. If there's
any I cannot see your hand. So
hop in if you
anyone, I think there's a
question in the q&a. Oh, uh,
sorry.
Um,
let's see.
Tim Jackson, what
was his history with brother
blue? I always thought it was
wonderful for the storytellers
legacy that he was in
nightriders.
Adam Charles Hart: Yeah, um, I
don't have a ton of insights
into that. He was George's
pretty terrible at keeping
records. And most of the
production documents that we
have are from the 80s 90s and
2000s, when somebody else was
keeping records. So we don't
have a ton. But what I do know
about brother blue is that he
was somebody that George knew
from Pittsburgh, like he just he
knew him from, like, working in
or, you know, like, traveling in
the same circles. He was local
color, not unlike, you know,
Heather and I are both huge fans
of a documentary called Sweet
Sal. That's about just like a
local guy in Braddock, who's,
you know, strange and delightful
and just completely charismatic
and charming. And George just
put him in his movie in night
writers. And, you know, he had
written the part of Merlin for
a, like, a black man,
supposedly, Morgan Freeman read
for the part. But he only read
for the part. This is the way
George would tell the story, so
that he could lecture George
afterwards and say, this part
should be a part for a man, not
a black man said, well, it says
in the script, black man, and
that's the character. And so
it's a strange little anecdote.
But I think he always had
brother blue in mind for it.
Like whether or not he could
have hired Morgan Freeman, that
would certainly put the it would
put the film into it would make
it something else for sure. But
he is he's kind of him himself.
Like he's given a character and,
you know, lions and all of that.
But he's asked to bring that
sort of local color in a way
that Ramiro often likes to do in
his movies, especially at that
time, when he was, you know,
really sort of tapped into
Pittsburgh, I guess.
Heather Hendershot: Great. Well,
thank you. And thank you, Ambar,
for pointing out that I'd missed
that one in the q&a. Um, I think
maybe we're ready to wrap up.
Thank you so much, Adam, for
your time and presenting all
this really interesting
material. And I encourage anyone
who has more questions or
thoughts or follow up to get in
touch with Adam directly. And
I'm sure there's so much more to
share. So thank you for joining
us.
Adam Charles Hart: Thanks,
Heather. Thanks. Thanks, Scott.
Thanks, everybody. This was a
lot of fun. And, yeah, no, I put
my email address in the chat.
And you know, if anybody has any
follow ups, please feel free. I
obviously loves talking about
stuff so don't, don't hold back.
Heather Hendershot: Thanks so
much. All right, I'm going to
end this meeting now then
Bye everyone. Thank yo
Adam Charles Hart: thank you.